[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je vais demander à franck
antoine lui bien de beau vouloir venir
avec bien sûr alors on va et je sais que
vous adorez cette séquence chez vous ça
l'attentât bluff
vous allez un bluff vous allez regarder
dans la tente ce qu'il y a vous allez
décrire aux téléspectateurs et à nos
chroniqueurs c'est que vous voyez vous
les trouvez nous dirait qu'ils bluffent
qui dit la vérité
moi je regarderai je dirais un truc et
vous vous dire un truc tous les trois
mois je vais vous dire ce que je vois
dans la tente
le moule dit je vois bernard montiel en
train de prendre un coup de soleil il se
trouvait et franck qu'est ce que vous
voulez l'aider
allez-y tous les relais venez me dit oui
c'est sûr produire assez surprenante
attaché désolé pour cet album mais
qu'est ce qu'on voit là bulgare
physiquement donc je crois qu il est
horrible épouvantable mais ça alors
c'est quoi qui joue à la souris
c'est un cauchemar tu vois le vous pros
riblon fra bat moi ce que tu vois à adé
pas prendre parti moi je vois bernard
montiel
mais non et c'est moi qui vois pas bien
d'un jeu on a bien géré
[Applaudissements]
ça fait combien de temps que tu ne vois
pas pourquoi quelqu'un d'autre merci
alors moi je vois mokobé mokobé du 113
avec un lama la main je vois ce que
c'est mais mokobé celui 113 je sais pas
qui c'est regardez regardez sous loyer
mokobé du 113 avec un là-bas mais moi je
vois une voix la roma alors qu'est ce
que vous voyez est ce que tu deviendras
un homard et vue ouais moundir va
aiguiser en frères bogdanoff
voilà la raison
patrick bloche donc patrick chirac doit
vous prenez mon sexuelle bob penser car
croyez qu'un mokobé aucun lama vous oui
vous dites la vérité ça soit dans vos
yeux c'est bon je crois moundir je crois
pas trop ou croyez moi caroline va
regarder
[Applaudissements]
connecte avec une housse entrait je vais
regarder cela dans cette troisième
cabinet iri tous ont refusé alors moi je
vais vous dire ce que je vois là je vois
je vois gérard louvin géant à louvain en
train de boire un verre gilles maury tôt
possible a rien à [ __ ]
est ce que vous voyez vous alors bon de
voir c'est moi je vois michel drucker
complètement bourré alors michel drucker
bourré ou gérard louvin cyril bluff si
l'epa créant michel ribes et bien sûr
jean luc blanc s'en sert il
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est mon cas
pato et marichez le papier
[Musique]